Nadia Drake: Well, I do want to ask you
about the sharpest new
shiny space telescope in the shed
which happens to be here,
the James Webb Space Telescope,
or JWST.
Heidi Hammel: We already knew back then
in the late 80s, 1990s,
that the universe was expanding.
And we knew that to see
the very first galaxies
and maybe even the first stars
that ever formed in the universe --
Because of the expansion of the universe,
the light from those galaxies
is likewise expanded,
and it's shifted from blue wavelengths
to longer wavelengths, red wavelengths.
And so the concept then
for the next generation space telescope
was to build an advanced telescope
that really focused
on the infrared part of the spectrum,
because that's where we could see
the first stars and the first galaxies.
I knew that this telescope
that was being built to find it,
to probe the light
from the first galaxies,
would also be a fabulous tool
to study Neptune and Uranus.
I mean, I just knew that
because I knew it would be big enough.
I knew that because it was
a space telescope,
the images would be stable and pristine.
And I knew that these wavelengths
of light in the infrared
had all sorts of interesting
molecular signatures
so that we could learn
about the upper atmospheres
of these planets.
And so I’m like, “I’m in. I’ll do this.”
So in 2002, I wrote a proposal saying
I would like to be an interdisciplinary
scientist for this program
to ensure that this telescope will be able
to do solar system observations
when it is launched.
And in 2003, my proposal was accepted,
and that was how I formally
became involved in this telescope.
So Webb --
It's different than Hubble.
It's a different kind of telescope
for a number of reasons.
One is it's a lot bigger than Hubble.
It’s a six-and-a-half-meter mirror --
the golden mirror, the collecting area --
versus Hubble's two point four.
ND: It’s so big that it couldn’t
be launched looking like that.
It had to be all folded up.
HH: That’s right. It had to be folded up.
And that's why the mirror is segments.
ND: Yeah.
HH: So that it could be folded up.
ND: Like a honeycomb.
HH: Like a honeycomb, exactly.
ND: But then it had to unfold in space.
And I remember how nervous
people were about this process
because it really was something
that everything,
every single step had to go right.
HH: Not only did the telescope
have to fold up,
but we -- if you look at Webb,
it's got this huge contraption
underneath it,
which we call a sunshield.
And that's crucial for this telescope.
ND: How did you feel as you were
witnessing the deployment sequence?
HH: I sure was nervous,
just like everybody else.
There were several single point failures
where if that thing
didn't unbolt or unfold,
we didn't have
a working telescope anymore.
So it was extremely nerve-racking.
But we had many years of testing
because we knew that there was
no fixing this telescope.
This telescope's not
in low earth orbit like Hubble.
The James Webb Space Telescope
is a million miles away
at a point called the L2 Point,
and it was put out there deliberately
because it needed to be cold.
It needed to have the sunshield
to protect the telescope
from the warmth of the Sun,
the warmth of the Earth
and even the warmth of our Moon.
So the sunshield is designed
to be like an umbrella that protects it,
a sun umbrella that keeps
that telescope super cold.
So we couldn't put it in low earth orbit
because it's just too warm
in that environment.
You can't sense infrared light
when it's hot.
You have to have it cold.
By the way, that's also why this telescope
is completely exposed
to the elements of space.
Most other telescopes
have tubes that enclose them,
and this one doesn't.
The mirrors are just sitting out there.
ND: They're just out there.
HH: They're just sitting out there.
ND: So the first deep field from JWST,
I think the analogy I heard
was that the image itself
covers about the amount of space
as a grain of rice on a fingertip
held at arm's length.
Is that right?
HH: I heard a grain of sand,
not a grain of rice.
But it's the same concept,
you know, that -- yeah.
If you -- the piece of sky
you see in that picture,
if you were like standing in your backyard
and looking up in the sky,
that piece of sky is about the same size
as a tiny grain of sand.
If you moved your grain of sand
over to the left,
you would see more galaxies,
and over to the left again, more galaxies.
And anywhere you looked in the sky,
it is filled with galaxies.
ND: Just thousands and thousands
in that one image alone.
HH: Exactly. What I'm waiting for
is the James Webb
Space Telescope Deep Field,
where we stare for days at a dark spot
that we don't know where anything is.
What are we going to see?
And then, think about that,
going to be all over the whole sky.
Our universe is going to mentally expand
at that moment when we get that deep field
from James Webb Space Telescope.
It's going to be mind-blowing.
ND: I just think about it.
Peering so far back in time
to the beginning of
the primordial cosmic murk.
HH: Yeah.
ND: When stars and galaxies
are just starting to turn on
and how different the universe was
and the fact that we humans
on this one little planet Earth
can craft an instrument
that has the capability
to let us see that,
13.5 billion years ago,
or whatever it ends up being,
is really phenomenal.
HH: Yeah.
I view it as an example
of what humanity can do
when we work for the greater good,
when we work as teams
and we have a goal.
This project required
thousands of people in multiple countries,
multiple states,
to take this vision
and turn it into a concrete thing,
this telescope.
And then launch it on a rocket,
and then have the ability
to use it, to probe
from right in our local neighborhood
all the way to the edge
of the known universe
and everything in between.
ND: Yeah.
HH: It's amazing to me.
And everybody had a role to play.
The beryllium miners
who mined the beryllium
we used to make the mirrors
and the cable wrappers
who wrapped the cables
to allow this thing to move,
and the people who
built the different instruments.
We have a suite
of four different instruments,
cameras and spectrographs.
Both here, in Europe.
You know, we all worked -- in Canada.
Canada made the fine guidance sensor
that allows us to point this thing.
I mean, it's a truly international effort
and it all comes together
to create this revolution
in how we see the cosmos.
ND: Do you have a favorite
among the images
that have been released so far?
HH: Well, they all have
special aspects about them
that make me go, “Wow!”
In the case of the “Cosmic Cliffs” image,
it’s beautiful, it’s blue in the dark
and orange in the bottom.
And, you know, I get excited
about images like that
because not only are they
tremendously beautiful
and evocative in a poetic way,
but those are places
where stars are being born.
And some of the little
pokey things that stick out,
that give it some
of its dramatic structure,
you know, those are --
that’s star birth in the making.
And I think that's just so cool.
And particularly when we use
our infrared cameras,
we can look inside some of those knobs
and see the stars that are being born.
And in some places,
like the Orion Nebula --
there was just an image released
of the Orion Nebula --
that’s places where
planetary systems are forming.
We aren't seeing the planets,
but we're seeing
the swirling disks of dust and gas
where those planets are being born.
And even some of these galaxy images,
while they may be static,
like the "Stephan's Quintet" image,
which is five galaxies --
one of which is an interloper,
it’s a foreground galaxy.
It’s not part of the other crew.
ND: Just wanted to be in the shot.
HH: It's just photobombing the other ones.
But the four that are part of a cluster,
what you learn from
James Webb Space Telescope
is that in the regions where they are
interacting and overlapping,
those regions light up in the infrared.
Those are places
where the dust and the gas
and the existing stars
of those other galaxies,
when they are interacting,
they are forming new stars.
They are creating new realms
of star formation,
and they just light up
in the infrared in that image.
ND: Yeah. And I just wonder, like,
what's missing from that picture?
What can JWST fill in?
I mean, how much more color can it add?
HH: What JWST adds to our ongoing story
is it adds new wavelengths of light
that we haven't had
the sensitivity to study,
and different wavelengths of light
tell you different parts of this story.
And we also use tools in astronomy
called spectrographs,
and that is where
we don't just take pictures,
but we actually take the light
and we spread it out
into its rainbow of colors.
And what we do is we look for what we call
fingerprints in that light, if you will.
Certain atoms and molecules
tend to absorb specific colors of light,
just by the very nature
of their construction,
and their motion and vibration.
They absorb certain colors of light.
So by spreading the light out
into a rainbow
and looking for patterns
in what light is missing,
that tells you what molecules are there.
And not only does it tell you
[which] are there,
it tells you their temperature.
It can tell you their pressures.
By tracking carefully
these lines in the spectrum,
you can determine
the motions of this material.
And so we don't just have
a static picture.
We can actually do
three-dimensional tomography
of astrophysical objects
by using this spectral light information.
But as an astronomer,
it's not just the pictures.
It is spreading that light out
and looking into its constituents,
that’s where the real,
deep science takes place.
That’s where you get
what stars are actually made of.
Like, helium, and the helium and hydrogen,
and beryllium and even iron and nickel.
How do you know that?
You can't go there and weigh it.
You learn it from the light.
ND: Can you tell us about that instrument
and what it might be able to show us
about Uranus and Neptune
and some of the other giant planets
that we haven't been able to see before?
How is this telescope going to help us
understand these worlds?
HH: Let's say you wanted
to study Jupiter's rings, right?
We know Jupiter has rings.
Voyager saw them.
But we know most planetary rings
change with time.
Trying to image the faint ring of Jupiter
next to the incredibly bright
planet of Jupiter
is extraordinarily difficult.
The rings are a million times
fainter than the planet,
and they're right next to it.
But James Webb Space Telescope,
the sensitivity is so good
and the imaging capability is so good
that the scattered light from Jupiter
does not spread even out
to the local place where the rings are.
So in our first images,
engineering images of Jupiter,
that were taken just to test
the scattered light on the camera --
they took a couple
of sharp, short images of Jupiter
and moved Jupiter closer and closer
to the fine guidance sensor
to see if it would screw up our guiding --
even in those short engineering images,
the rings are right there.
Beautiful.
Just totally resolved right next
to the planet a million times brighter.
ND: Well, can we talk about planets
outside the solar system, too?
HH: Sure. Yeah. What's your favorite?
ND: What's your favorite?
HH: Oh, I don't know.
I've got a couple of favorites.
ND: Yeah?
HH: I think a lot of astronomers’ ...
favorite system right now
is the TRAPPIST-1 system.
ND: Yeah. Tell me about it.
HH: TRAPPIST-1 is --
that's the name of the star.
TRAPPIST is the name of the survey, right?
But it looked at this star
and it discovered
that there are at least
seven planets orbiting this star.
And most of those planets
seem to be Earth-sized.
In the TRAPPIST-1 system,
several of the planets
are the right distance from the host star
that water could be liquid
on the surface of them.
We call that the habitable zone.
And you and I could have a long talk
about what habitability actually means.
But in our solar system,
at least on our Earth,
the only place that we know life exists,
there's a lot of water.
And so when we're talking
about looking for habitable planets,
we look at planets that are
at the right distance from their host star
that they could have water on them.
So that TRAPPIST system
that we know that there are planets
in potentially habitable region,
and that those planets
are roughly Earth-sized,
they are everybody's favorite right now
for JWST to take a look at
with our spectrographs.
ND: Yeah.
Do you think there is life
beyond Earth somewhere?
And if so, where?
HH: OK, so let me answer
the second question first.
This question of,
“is there alien life out there?”
I usually break it up into two things.
One is a thought experiment
about the size of the universe,
the scale of the universe,
just how many stars there are
in our galaxy.
And then how many galaxies?
There's billions of stars
just in our local galaxy.
And there's billions
of galaxies out there.
And we talk about whether or not
life could have formed
over the billions of years
that our universe has existed
with these billions of galaxies,
each of which has billions of stars.
I say life has to exist
somewhere out there.
Somewhere. [It] has to be out there.
Does that mean that aliens
have come to Earth and visited us?
No, that's a totally separate question.
I just -- it's not a related question.
That's a more psychological question.
I'm more interested
in the science aspect of the question.
I think we need to start
with terrestrial-sized planets
that are the right distance
to have water on them,
because those are the conditions required
to create life as we know it on Earth.
And the only kind of life
that we'll initially recognize
is going to be life like ours, I think.
ND: So JWST is one tool that we can use
in the search for life beyond Earth.
But there are others,
including within our own solar system:
some of the rovers that are on Mars,
currently looking
for signs of ancient biosignatures
or ancient signs of alien life
in the rocks there,
but also some of the missions
that are being planned
to the outer solar system,
and specifically some of the moons there.
I'm curious about whether you think
it's possible that life exists here
in our local neighborhood,
but beyond Earth.
HH: Hey, anything is possible.
I've learned in my career
never to deal in absolutes
because the universe is great
at throwing curveballs at you.
You know, when we have our rovers on Mars
and our orbiters that are doing
really exquisite orbital imaging,
it's clear that there's evidence
that at one time there was liquid water
on the surface of Mars.
There’s sedimentation,
there’s a chemical evidence,
there's, you know, actually water trapped
in the ices in the poles
of Mars right now.
And so it could very well be
that at some time in the past
that planet had liquid water
and may have had the conditions
for life to form.
We don't know.
It could be that life formed there first
and transmitted itself inward to us.
We could be Martians.
ND: We could be Martians.
HH: I don't know.
We don't know the answer to that.
Using our definition of looking
at places where there's liquid water,
you know, people sort of
initially confined it
to a certain distance
from the host star --
sort of from the Earth
just barely out to Mars
and maybe inward a little bit,
not quite as inward as Venus,
but they kind of limited it
to that region,
saying, “Well, Earth
is the Goldilocks zone.
That's why it's not too hot, not too cold.
That’s why life is here.”
But we've learned more
about our solar system
with the spacecraft and telescopes.
And one of the things
that we have learned with our missions
to the Jupiter system
and the Saturn system
is that some of the larger moons
in those systems
do have evidence of liquid water
in their interiors.
More water on Jupiter's moon,
more water inside Jupiter's moon, Europa,
that we have on the surface of the Earth,
which is kind of crazy. Think about it.
ND: It’s mind-boggling to think about.
HH: The question is,
could life form in that water?
And it gets back to what are
the ingredients you need for life?
You need water, but you also need
some kind of an energy source.
You need some kind of a surface
on which life can do
its chemical thing to form.
I'm not an astrobiologist,
so I don't know what the right lingo is,
but you need to have a surface
for stuff to happen.
And does Europa have those things?
Well, it doesn't have them on its surface.
Its surface is just ice.
But we know
from our various flybys of this --
we were able to map out its structure,
its internal structure,
by looking at the magnetic field
and how it interacts with it,
by looking at gravitational deflection --
we know that it probably has a solid core,
and we also know that Europa is warm.
Now, why would this moon
out there at Jupiter's distance,
why would it be warm, right?
Why would Jupiter’s other moon, Io,
have active volcanoes?
That's really warm. That's crazy warm.
And the answer is these moons actually
interact with one another.
They do like a little resonant dance
with each other as they orbit Jupiter.
And as they orbit one another
and interact with one another,
the gravity of these moons
makes very tiny flexes
in the shape of the moons,
but the flexes repeat over time
and that repeating warms the planet.
I used to illustrate this for kids
with old credit cards.
If you take an old credit card
and you bend it, bend it,
bend it, bend it,
and you feel where
you're bending, it's warm.
It's really the same process.
It's that flexing is what warms these.
So for Europa in orbit around Jupiter,
we have the water,
we have the rocky surface deep inside.
We have warmth.
We've got this energy source thing.
So is it possible
that life has formed there?
Sure.
Who am I to say no?
I mean, what do I know?
I mean, the universe is much more complex
than I can imagine.
So we are building a spacecraft
called the Clipper spacecraft,
which is going to go to the Jupiter system
and it's going to orbit Jupiter,
but it's going to do multiple flybys
of the moon Europa.
ND: So, Heidi, word on the street is
that you have a favorite moon.
What is it?
And there's only one right answer
to this question.
HH: My favorite moon is Triton.
ND: It's a pretty good one.
HH: It's not the right one, though?
ND: I was going to say Iapetus.
HH: No, no, no, no.
We're going to have
a long conversation about that.
ND: Tell me why Triton is better.
HH: Triton is such a cool moon.
It goes in a retrograde orbit
backwards around the planet.
We think it was actually
a Kuiper Belt object
that got too close to Neptune
and was captured by Neptune.
And it's a big moon.
I mean, if you want Pluto to be a planet,
I don't know where you stand
on that issue,
but Triton is twin to Pluto.
So it's like a planet
in orbit around another planet.
ND: But it’s going backwards.
HH: But it's going backwards
around the planet.
And when Voyager flew by in 1989,
it actually flew kind of close,
so we got a good view of one half of it.
And it's got remarkable terrain
and it has active cryovolcanoes on it.
There are volcanoes, ice volcanoes,
erupting on Triton, like, in real time.
So that's pretty amazing.
I mean, it's got an atmosphere, right?
And it could have
a liquid water ocean inside it.
So it may be an ocean world.
And since we know it's active,
because we saw it with Voyager,
that may be another abode for life.
ND: So, Heidi, how did you become
interested in astronomy?
What was it that lit that fire for you?
HH: It's kind of a goofy story,
but I think in one sense,
I became an astronomer
because I used to get carsick.
ND: Seriously?
HH: My family would go on road trips
and, you know,
I would be in the back of the car
and I'd be so sick and I couldn't read.
I couldn't do anything
except stare out the window.
And at night, staring out the window,
I started to recognize star patterns
like the Big Dipper and Orion.
And I became more familiar with them
because that's all I could do
is to stare out at the sky.
And so, you know, I think that
sort of kindled an interest for me.
But I had a math teacher who one day
took her class of four students aside
and said, "Where are you young people
planning to go to college?"
And when it came to my turn,
I said, "Penn State."
She said, "Why?"
And I said, “Well, my dad went
to Penn State and I live in Pennsylvania.”
She said, "I think
you should apply to MIT."
ND: Wow.
HH: And I said, "I don't even
know what that is."
So she encouraged me and I applied.
When it came time
for letters of recommendation,
I asked my chemistry teacher
to write me a letter, and he said no.
And I said, "Why not?"
He said, "You'll never get into MIT."
So I asked my history teacher instead,
and she did write a letter
and I did get into MIT.
And when I brought back
my acceptance letter
and showed it to my chemistry teacher --
“Look, I got into MIT.” --
he said, "It's only
because you're a woman.
They have quotas to fill."
This is in 1978 when people
said things like that to your face.
That made me angry more than anything.
So I was determined to go to MIT and --
graduate, you know.
ND: What are some of the most nagging
unanswered questions in your mind
that exist in astronomy?
Any field in astronomy,
could be anywhere in the universe,
close to home, far away.
What bugs you? What keeps you up at night?
HH: How did the first stars and galaxies
form in the universe?
We have lots of models and theories,
but to be able to make
actual observations as early as we can,
to tie together some
of the disparate observations we have
with a coherent story.
I think that is an area
that is very, very interesting right now.
And of course, that's why
James Webb Space Telescope was built,
to add a piece to that story.
ND: Uh-huh.
HH: I think I'm also interested
in how our planetary system
that we live in,
how did it in particular come to be
and how did it come to be habitable?
We know this is the only one ...
the only system that we know
is inhabited, right,
is our solar system.
ND: Right.
HH: Is it required that you have
giant planets in the outer system
and small planets
in the inner solar system
to make habitability?
Or is it just by happenstance?
Did you have to have a Jupiter
to make it habitable?
Did you have to have a Neptune
to sweep out through the Kuiper Belt
and deliver volatiles
to the inner solar system,
water and stuff?
I mean, that's so interesting. And ...
And it touches us as humans.
Like, how did we come to be?
It's part of our story,
it's part of our life story.
So I'm very interested
in that question as well.
And we still have
so many observations left to make,
both within our solar system
and in the greater universe.
I think astronomers will be busy
for a long time to come.